hopes rumors and then actual news of a
movie based on the long-running TV
classic The Simpsons floated around for
years before the Simpsons movie was
released in 2007 it was worth the wait
a hilarious animated adventure with a
big story but fitting the big screen the
film made more than 500 million dollars
at the worldwide box office it's been
ten years since everyone's favorite four
fingered Springfield residents proved
they could make the jump from television
so how come they haven't made the
Simpsons movie - yet a good idea the
show's writers and producers don't want
to attempt another big screen project
just for the sake of doing it it's such
a monumental project with millions of
dollars at stake in millions of fans
with exacting standards that they'll
only make another Simpsons movie if
they've got a really good idea one
that's really worth a 90-minute
treatment during a Simpsons panel at the
2016 San Diego comic-con writer producer
Al Jean addressed the possibility of
doing another Simpsons Movie we talked
about it
but it's you know if we do it we only
want to do it if it's gonna be really
good already used it at one point the
writers actually thought they had a
great idea for the next Simpsons movie
in an episode initially conceived as the
24th season finale Kang and kodos the
humongous booming voice aliens that have
appeared in numerous treehouse of horror
Halloween specials kidnapped The
Simpsons family from Disneyland and take
them to their distant Hall Planet of
Rigel 7 where Homer is nearly eaten al
gene who co-wrote the episode with David
Mirkin decided with Simpsons executive
producer James L Brooks that the plot
was so ambitious that they should use it
for the next simpsons movie gene told
Entertainment Weekly we were worried
that people might think it's an idea
that's not canonical because the plot is
so far gone from the generally realistic
scenarios of The Simpsons the script
went back into the episode pile and
aired as the man who came to be dinner
in 2015 too many ideas perhaps the real
problem isn't that the Simpsons writers
don't have a good idea for a sequel it's
that they can't pick just one
for example before they settled on the
plot of the first Simpsons Movie
the writers floated several large-scale
movie worthy concepts the fourth season
episode Camp Krusty in which Bart and
Lisa attend a terrifying decrepit summer
camp that descends into nightmarish
chaos was nearly a movie Matt Groening
wanted to make a Fantasia parody called
simp take insisting of short animated
sequences set to music and before his
death in 1998 Phil Hartman planned on
making a live-action film about his
Simpsons character b-movie actor Troy
McClure Matt Groening isn't thrilled any
Simpsons movie has to get the sign-off
from Simpsons creator and executive
producer Matt bringing even 30 years
after his characters debuted on the
Tracey Ullman Show he's still very much
involved with any and all major
decisions affecting his price creation
and as far as the sequel goes he's in no
rush why the first one was a grind in a
2009 interview graining said the first
movie was an experience that left and
frustrated in part because he and other
members of the creative team thought it
would take two years to produce but it
ended up taking four while speaking at
UCLA Law School in 2013 graining said
the first film quote stole animators
from the show and drained resources at
the same speaking engagement Simpsons
producer and director David Silverman
estimated that another movie would
happen in another 10-15 years
busy Simpsons James L Brooks The
Simpsons executive producer since the
show debuted in 1989 told The Hollywood
Reporter that the Simpsons creative team
hasn't made another movie because
they're doing a lot of other stuff
Brooks meant that whatever time the
Simpsons makers have for work outside
the show itself is spent on Simpsons
related extracurricular activities such
as a series of live Simpsons shows of
the Hollywood vault for developing the
scores of Simpsons bonus material for
the Simpsons world app it's the all new
Simpsons ride a peak times The Simpsons
is still on TV probably the main
impediment preventing the Simpsons
writers cast and crew from making
another Simpsons movie is The Simpsons
the same people who'd make another movie
are already pretty busy making 22
episodes of the show every year that's a
huge workload episodes take months
between conception and full animation so
each is a lengthy and costly endeavor
involving a small army of employees
Simpsons producer and director David
Silverman told Entertainment Weekly in
2017 that a sequel is daunting because
it really knocked the stuffing out of us
to do the movie and the show at the same
time if the crew doesn't want to make a
movie at the same time as the show don't
expect that sequel anytime soon The
Simpsons has been renewed until at least
2019 Fox hasn't ordered one yet
while another Simpsons movie would be a
surefire hit and a no brainer for all
involved
the fact remains that studio 20th
century-fox hasn't technically asked for
one yet
the creative team isn't about to move
mountains to make another movie until
they're officially asked and contracts
are signed otherwise why work on
something that might not get made
anytime soon or ever nevertheless
Simpsons writer producer Al Jean says a
movie is in its earliest stages which
probably means the show's writers are
tossing around ideas and getting a game
plan together for if and win their
corporate bosses ever commissioned a
Simpsons movie sequel keep those stubby
yellow fingers crossed thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]